so ladies if Ke$ha is your type please
step forward
[Music]
tough luck they're shy first boy out the
waves of love are in motion fans are
filled with devotion but what happens
when love lust and late comers cause an
epic emotion this is love after the
island
[Music]
hey sexy beaches welcome to love after
the island your official love island
recap show i'm lauren zima here to talk
all the tropical T in love islands
explosive season premiere on CBS and
joining me to weigh in on all the drama
is a longtime love island superfan and
the host of the fabulous podcast keep it
on crooked media thank you for being
here IRA Madison the third thank you
okay so you are a love island superfan
you watched the British version all the
seasons and now we finally have our own
version here in the US how did you feel
about the premiere I thought it was
really fun yes
yeah it's basically a lot like the
British show but it's weird hearing no
accent we're so American I have to tell
you you and I are coming at it from
different perspectives because you're
this longtime superfan I was coming at
it with fresh eyes and I was instantly
obsessed I loved it because it didn't
just bring drama but these people were
really funny I was laughing at you know
a little cheer we had are kind of
secretly perhaps villainous and Cashel
or as Carol called him at first cashew
we're still learning everybody's names
yeah there's a lot of people and so you
sort of have to get used to you know
it's that reality TV show thing of you
never know who they are until what like
two weeks huh yes until they suddenly
become a villain right off the bat
anybody who knowing the show knowing how
it works you thought ooh that person's
someone to watch so like they always
save the best person to come in last
because they have to steal somebody and
they really have to have a strong
personality to give you that like I'm
here to steal someone but I want to
pretend like I want to be friends with
everyone but we're really here to play a
game and that's what it really kicks the
game off and that's why I love Kira Kira
I mean that's the thing I've been
hearing that this show was super
addictive and that's why I think I'm
gonna be addicted to this because we had
mascara come in and shake things up so
much so quickly and we really saw how
things can turn on a dime there one
couple and that was Carol and Cashel so
let's take a look so that we make sure
we're on the same page about the
fabulous format of love island as quick
as a way of
to the shore we saw how savage things
that can become when the first man who
arrived Cashel did not get picked by any
of the ladies tough luck
they're shy first boy out Kara why
didn't you step forward are you very
handsome but you were a bit too shy for
me
all right look - I was desperately so
it's mutual selection the ladies are all
standing there looking lovely in their
bikinis and high heels Cashel comes out
and our fabulous hosts arielle
vandenberg says step forward if you're
interested nobody steps forward karo
says you seem too shy which I don't know
what she was basically and then he picks
her what kind of a move is that in the
love island game to pick somebody who's
straight up said I'm not interested in
you you know it sort of means that I
feel like he's really there to play the
game he's confident yeah at first he
seemed like he was a little like maybe
he was shy he's a little right and that
could be the character who ends up being
someone's best friend you know and like
maybe they don't really find a match ah
but it turned out that's not really the
case they turned out this was not the
case I felt like I was on such a roller
coaster with Cairo and Cashel from the
beginning of the episode to the end so
it's a mutual selection process the
couples wind up coupled up even if they
aren't necessarily happy about their
couples we had Michael and Alexandra
Cashel or she called him cashew in Cairo
Weston and Mallory
yeah man in Alana Zac and Elizabeth so
everybody's hot and sexy and paired up
and now this is when things get real
except as you pointed out our fabulous
Kira comes in and tell me what's going
through your head when you see Kira come
in at the end after everyone's already
coupled up so Kira coming in you're
already hoping that she's gonna be a
strong personality right and she comes
in and she's hot from the second I saw
her I'm like oh we have kind of I have
to say it maybe saved the best for last
she's she turned some heads on the
British version and they're always
talking about someone turning someone's
head you know when couples are together
if you're really sort of nervous that
someone's going to come in and steal
your man or steal your girl
you're always like assuring the person
that you're in a couple with that no one
can turn my head if they come into the
villa but he returns some heads
yeah I felt like we saw the guys take a
look at her how could you miss her and
you know we find out as the episode goes
on like she's dated a woman before she's
this musician she's this model she likes
free spirits and like Oh Kira he's like
got a good heart but here to shake
things she's like the perfect reality TV
content like I'm an Instagram model I'm
a musician
I'm into women and man like there's no
stopping here yeah so casual chose to
couple up with Cairo even though she was
not into him so much so that this
Spitfire said they should both feel just
fine
flirting with other Islanders it was I
am attracted to Mike for let's be real
who is unattractive and like like you're
so handsome and then your personality
makes you even like more like attractive
okay
so I am super excited to get to know you
a lot of yes and it's okay right for you
to go around and like talk to dude I'm
gonna do the same yeah same thing like I
want to know everybody yeah like you and
me are like right here I can feel it we
a team we're the C's CC CC okay I when I
watching that I'm thinking they're
friends
there's no sexuality here that you're
literally saying to each other and I
sort of felt Kasia was playing along
with Cairo saying what she wanted to
hear but she seems so confident she's
saying I'm gonna go flirt with other
guys here's exactly who I find
attractive right and he was sort of
really playing that up as he said you
know he's sort of like oh yeah you know
like I just want to see who else is in
Mozilla too you know I'm like oh yeah
everyone finds Michael attractive and
you sort of maybe see I head there that
he's sort of that's his flirting
mechanism right it's this sort of like
the night I'm like the nice guy and
and all of a sudden these girls come to
me totally
he feels like the safe bet until he
turns totally vicious that was what we
saw as the episode went on Cashel and
Caro are agreeing to flirt with other
people I mean - we're just gonna be
friends which can happen on the show to
me back when this happened where people
are couples but really there's no
sexuality there yet so what happens is
if a person is less single they're
vulnerable and they might leave the
island right so if you're friends with
someone you may continue to pick them
you know reek up in ceremonies so that
they don't go home this is the thing
that I feel like I'm going to get so
obsessed with about this show is both
watching it to see real feelings that
people have but also watching it to see
how they're really playing this game
because at the end of it you can win a
hundred thousand dollars if you're the
last couple standing yeah okay so
there's real stakes here that money that
makes it real so Kira comes in she is
gonna have her pick she is going to be
able to choose what guys she wants who
were you thinking she was most
interested in she seemed to like Weston
a lot and she also seemed like he gay
men I feel you on that because she was
very clear about saying to Weston you're
not normally my type but I'm into you
and I think here's the type who is happy
to think outside her oh gosh yes and I
am is having a hard time telling but it
seems like Kara was getting very worried
very jealous that Kira might pick her
boy Cashel Cashel so we saw the feelings
get real casual and Caro suddenly seemed
to be flirting with each other I will my
jaw was on the floor here's how the show
works night one you've got to spend the
night in bed with your coupled up person
now we thought these two were just
friends and all of a sudden she's
caressing his face and he's giving her
forehead kisses yeah IRA what's going on
here do you believe these feelings well
so I feel like it's this thing where
you're isolated and you're in this villa
right and I mean if you haven't been in
a relationship for a bit I don't know
the particulars statuses but you know
like if you're in bed with a hot guy all
of a sudden you know it's like oh I want
to cuddle with somebody here oh did say
it's been a while since I felt quote
male energy
he was all for it I was so surprised and
you're so right about it being the
psychological aspect of things I'm
thinking this woman just a minute ago
was telling him she was gonna flirt with
other people but now has she this
quickly gotten sucked into the
environment of love Island and all that
it can do and now she wants forehead
kisses from him and it looks like she
did uh-huh
so they're flirting but from cuddle town
when the lights went down to drama in
the harsh light of day Caro went from
not knowing cashews name to being
totally nuts for everything else what
would you do if she picks you I don't
know can you not haven't even talked
because now I'm sorry that I ended up
kissing I were the power of love Island
I mean these people have known each
other for less than 24 hours at work and
I feel like I'm watching a couple months
into dating have kind of their first
fight about jealousy and flirting with
other people yeah and the kiss came
really quickly I think it's like this
combination of the fact that one he
picked her first right and none of the
other guys stole her away from him and
then this other girl comes in Kira and
all of a sudden she maybe has eyes for
casuals she has a cure hasn't told her
at this point Yeah right I love that
Kerr was sort of being coy about who she
was into but Kara she's a little nervous
you know she's like I don't wanna leave
the island so you think that Cairo is
more worried about leaving the islands
than maybe having super strong feelings
for couch Wars it's all swirling in her
head yeah I mean she was crying yeah
because her - might be different if
another guy had walked into the villa
right I saw a power shift because Cairo
felt in the power position with Cashel
she didn't want him he picked her she
wasn't happy about it but then all of a
sudden of
josh'll might have another opportunity
here and I think that no matter who you
are how confident you are when you feel
a little rejected you can get on your
feelings a little bit and she was
getting in her feelings I'm greedy
she's parts so we have karo
we have cashew we'll call them Cashel
and then we got the third c-word crying
and you guys this is episode one I don't
know why I'm getting emotional like I
didn't like think this whole Kyra out
the coupling thing was gonna affect me
then much it's very overwhelming she's
overwhelmed she was standing there she's
about to pick her guy and Caro is
literally wiping tears from her eyes she
has gone from telling this man to flirt
with other people to wrapping her legs
around him saying your mind I don't want
her to start that night with you and and
she's sobbing over this this is the love
island effect love island does and
that's why you see it's so addictive
right you know it's just watching these
people and they think they're sort of
here for this fun summer vacation and
then immediately once someone comes in
the game ratchets it up yeah I will say
that this having watched the British
versions this is one of the quickest
leaps into drama and insanity I've ever
seen so the American version has come
into play the American version is
cracking on and bringing it IRA I love
this all right being the longtime fan
that you are make a couple calls for me
right now about the players that we've
seen so far in the game like do you have
a villain prediction do you have a most
sought-after prediction who give me
villain first who do you think could
really be a problem person in the house
and cause drama and get into fights I
think Michael you know that model
Michael it's a model he seems a little
self-involved I think that he could
really sort of get a lot of women
interested he was definitely the head
turner as you said when he walked in all
the ladies were taking a look at Michael
and he raised red flags for me because
he said some contradictory things he
said uh what am i into about a woman
booty and beauty but then he also said
he hadn't
like slept with anyone in a long time
and he was into personal I'm like you're
contradicting yourself I really like
Kira you do yeah I think that she's
gonna sort of be like a force to be
reckoned with in the show most sought
after by the guys it feels like yeah but
also things are starting so fast on this
show faster than I've sort of been used
to one love
well IRA we know you are an incredible
TV expert so I'm gonna trust your
opinions on this and I can't wait to
watch more we obviously weren't the only
people watching as Summers latest hit
some of our CBS faves that gathered
together to join in on the island fun
and they had major thoughts and just
like IRA and I check it out what do
think the biggest challenge is going to
be for these couples
I mean temptation right privacy it's
like it was one thing I was wondering I
was like they're all sleeping in the
same room yeah we just thing to see if
somebody hooks up with everybody just
like right in the next man you know yeah
and like are they going to like switch
beds in the Roma night and then like the
girls are gonna start stabbing each
other in the back oh yeah and the boys I
feel like doodle - yeah I feel like it's
gonna get I feel like we're gonna have
our share of like I thought it was sexy
love island was sexy fun hot I think
that the cast is amazing and I just
can't wait to see all the trouble that
they're gonna be getting to like ha ha
ha
I love the show it's so good good idea
CBS yeah and they're so hot everybody's
so hot the girls and the guys I'm
obsessed now listen up all you lovers do
you want your chance yes yours at
winning the hearts of one of our sexy
Islanders you guys you might have a shot
yes casting is not over go to cbs.com
for your shot at the fabulous Fiji Villa
you could join in oh and get in on all
the tropical T yourself we've officially
filled our love tank support today and I
want to give a special thanks to the
incredible IRA Madison the third for
your wisdom for your guidance for
cracking on with us thank you guys
check out IRAs podcast
- on crooked media if you have not it is
just as addictive as love island and of
course tune in to love island five
nights a week only on CBS and CBS all
access and every Friday we'll be back
here on love after the island for a
weekly Kiki with exclusive content from
the Islanders themselves fresh off the
beach and celebrity guests will join to
weigh in on all the tropical tea you
won't want to miss it from our cozy
Cabana here in California this has been
IRA Madison the third and I'm Lauren
Zima stay cool sexy beaches
[Music]
you
[Music]